good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric Kershaw our guest today is
Yale historian Beverly gage an expert in
20th century US history including the
presidency today we'll talk about
history in the making the 2012
presidential election now just three
weeks away
as always we'll ask some of your
questions they're really thanks for
joining us thanks Eric
so we're three weeks away three weeks
from today what's on your mind what are
you thinking about as we approach this
election well I think one of the things
that stands out to me about this
election as a historian is that there
are certain elections where to be frank
the candidates don't really matter right
where what happens moment to moment in
the campaign who makes a good speech how
the debate goes it just doesn't really
matter because the election has been
decided far in a way in advance for a
variety of other reasons and what's been
really striking about this campaign is
just how much the candidates do matter
and how much we really are uncertain
three weeks out about who's gonna make
mistakes about what the final narrative
is going to be and about how it's all
going to shake out what has contributed
to that uncertainty would you say
especially well I think you've had a
number of factors in play so obviously
the economy which always plays a big
role in the elections has played a very
significant role here and I think to
some degree the Republicans ambivalence
about their own candidate about Mitt
Romney I personally along with I think
many many other people don't think that
Romney has run a particularly good
campaign in some ways it seemed like
this might be an election for the
Republicans to either win or lose based
on how they campaigned based on what
they put forth and Romney's had a very
shaky time of it so I think in terms of
why is it not a slam-dunk for Barack
Obama we can see all sorts of reasons
but many of which have to do with the
state of the economy but why Mitt Romney
hasn't actually come out and done a
better job at pressing all of that home
is sort of a different set of questions
now one thing Mitt Romney unquestionably
has done well so far is debate although
I suppose you could are
that perhaps the president didn't debate
as well as we all expected him to and
and that may look better but we've got
the second base debate tonight it's a
close race debates how often have they
proven decisive in presidential history
if ever I know people often talk about
the Kennedy Nixon debates right
yeah the Kennedy Nixon debate is sort of
the famous example of a moment when a
debate really had an influence of course
that was a long time ago now and one of
the reasons that it remains the example
of the moment when a debate had a real
influence is that there haven't really
been a lot of debates since then in
which you can say the election turned on
this moment again I mean Kennedy Nixon
was a very very close race there are
people who would argue that actually
Richard Nixon he didn't win the debate
but you know there are people who would
argue that he actually won the election
but again a very very close election and
so in instances like that tends to be a
moment when the debate matters I'd say
the other thing that often comes out of
debates are memorable one-liners
memorable zingers you can in fact sort
of put something to rest a set of
concerns you can sort of exceed
expectations not live up to expectations
those sorts of things which can shift
the narrative in more subtle ways but
usually it's not a make-or-break factor
except to the degree that when you're
talking about tiny tiny numbers of
voters that need to shift their votes or
their ideas it can matter one thing we
haven't
it doesn't seem we've heard it quite as
much about as one might expect given the
turmoil in the world in the last few
years is foreign policy and we've got a
question from from a member of the
public named Jonathan Elgar he writes in
by Twitter to ask why the low focus on
foreign policy so far despite despite
the sort of interdependence of foreign
policy issues in our economic welfare
and so on and so forth alright well I
think there are a couple of things to
note so foreign policy was actually a
pretty substantial part of the vice
presidential debate so I think it did it
did serve rise up in part because the
woman who was doing the questioning was
in fact a foreign correspondent but I
think in part because it's not
big area where there are differing
opinions at the moment I mean for Barack
Obama and Mitt Romney to go at it there
are some subtle differences there are
some important differences but these are
first of all not the issues that they
believe are going to drive the campaign
and then secondly you know they are not
issues where the differences are quite
as stark as you might claim that they
are at least in areas like the economy
in areas like political ideology those
sorts of things and it's it's my
understanding that that incumbent
presidents often find foreign policy
kind of dangerous ground although it
would seem that Barack Obama has some
pretty important foreign policy
victories that he could trumpet and I
think it was something bin Laden of
course do you think that he's likely to
make a big issue of any of that or are
we really going to stick to the domestic
issues that that American voters are
most likely to care about right I think
it really depends what their assessment
of what's gonna move voters is going to
be and then these next three weeks right
that is all that anybody is doing in
these next three weeks I think on the
bin Laden question it's a little bit
touchy for Obama right because he has to
it is a kind of big symbolic victory on
the other hand does he want to seem to
be kind of riding this and taking
advantage of it does that open him up to
more criticism or not I think that
that's a really an open question at this
point and I do think however that one of
the things that bin Laden did in terms
of thinking about narratives is that it
did make Obama less vulnerable on
foreign policy right so it also made
sort of foreign policy questions harder
for the Republicans to push as hard as
they might have and as hard as they did
in say 2008 and 2004 in 2000 I guess to
some degree as well we're gonna take
another question this one comes though
has come in by email from Michael
Michael asks or points out that people
often say the USA politics in this
country is too partisan and too divided
and he asked is it true that our
politics now are more divisive and
combative than in past eras certainly
we've had
combat in the past political combat and
and based on history when does when does
partisan fighting go from being a
productive part of the democratic
process to being a destructive force in
our society well that is a question that
people have been debating how much
partisanship is doing how much
partisanship is too much partisanship
really since the country's founding and
it is certainly the case you know I sort
of like to remind students when we have
a question about bipartisanship about
partisan ranker and political rhetoric
that you know there was a civil war so
we are not as divided as we have ever
been right there have been many more
dramatic things that happened that said
I do think that what we're seeing right
now is not just a shift in the political
language which i think is often the way
in which it's it's talked about but
there have been really important and I
think sort of under-recognized shifts in
our political institutions and how our
parties operate that have happened
really since the 1970s that in some ways
feed into a structural lack of
cooperation that is quite different from
what we would have seen in the middle of
the twentieth century it's quite clear
now as opposed to say 50 or 60 years ago
that the parties are largely ideological
parties which is to say that the most
conservative democrat is to the left of
the most liberal republican at this
point and that really was not the case
for better or worse in the 20th century
kind of the middle part of the 20th
century so I think that the moderates
have been squeezed out well I don't know
I mean in part it is that moderates have
been squeezed out it is simply also that
the parties themselves have become more
ideologically uniform so for instance
you know in the 1950s for much of the
20th century really till the civil
rights movement you know you had a very
powerful conservative southern block
that was in the Democratic Party you
also had a kind of string of liberal
Republicans it's less of a block but
certainly a liberal Republican tradition
and since then partly as the South has
shifted into the Republican Party and
has become a red area instead of the
solid blue area that it was for much of
the 20th century
you know you've seen the the flavor and
the character of the parties change
right in the sense that they are more
ideologically driven they are less
region-based though of course ideology
and region sort of go go hand in hand in
certain ways so I think there are a lot
of structural developments like that
that aren't talked about as much another
one is the use of the primary election
which has been around for a long time
was around for most of the 20th century
but really only gained the currency that
it has today beginning in the 1970s and
primaries are good for any number of
reasons right and they were sort of
brought about as a way to democratize
the political panel was that well so
primaries were sort of a progressive era
idea and so a lot of primaries started
in the early 20th century but it's
really in the aftermath of the 1968
Democratic convention and and other
things that happened in the 60s and 70s
that you begin to get primaries being
really the chief way in which parties
put the candidates as opposed to
conventions as opposed to conventions as
opposed to some blend of primaries and
conventions you had a much more mixed
process and so that tends to drive
candidates that appeal to the party's
base right which tends to also drive a
certain amount of ideological division
so I think there are are we living in an
era of wonderful bipartisan cooperation
no is it as bad as it has ever been
probably not that either but I think the
really key thing is that there are a lot
of reasons for this that go beyond sort
of what people feel in their hearts and
and the ways in which we use our
political language I think there are a
lot of important structural things to
talk about when you teach about the
presidency are there are there certain
main points that you really want your
students to to leave with what is it
about the office of the presidency that
you like to convey you think it's
important to convey well to some degree
I think what I like to convey are some
of the limits on presidential power
which is to say that I often find myself
as a history
Korean journalists even the public as a
whole presidents make for very neat and
easy narratives right you go from this
person to this person you have a
struggle there are two sides something
results and then you have a single
figure in which to to kind of look at
the ways in which political shifts
happen you know it could be argued that
we devote an inordinately say
congressional elections to other areas
of court justice appointments or even
people who exercise enormous power in
the government who are not elected at
all so I think it's worth thinking both
about some of the limits on the
presidency and also at the ways in which
the presidency really has changed a
tremendous amount over time people's
expectations of what a president is
going to do what he is going to be
responsible for how they themselves
relate to the presidency as an
institution as an office the level of
intimacy that they feel I think the
relationship between president and
public and the ways that that's changed
over time is pretty pretty interesting
as well correct me if I'm wrong but
there was a time maybe a hundred years
ago even I should say as recently as a
hundred years ago when the president
didn't really campaign that hard in
public for the office it was considered
somewhat unseemly for the president to
do so how did that change well it
changed over time like most things but
yeah it was considered I mean if you had
been around in say 1912 which was one of
the most interesting elections in
American history and we're now at the
hundredth anniversary of it so there's a
lot of discussion of 1912 and and what
it means you actually did see some some
degree of kind of you know riding the
train around the country making speeches
I mean particularly someone like but you
have nothing to do so Taft was reluctant
to do so and for many years after that
in fact it was considered unseemly to
for instance appear at your party's
political convention in order to accept
the nomination because the conventions
were more important and because if you
were there it meant that you were
campaigning and seeking power and so
people like Woodrow Wilson as he's
waiting waiting waiting to see if he's
going to get the Democratic nomination
no he's off playing golf while the
conventions going on so you know I think
most people look at this and see a shift
both in in public expectations of the
president and in the technologies of
campaigning a lot of this begins to
shift in the 1930s primarily around
Franklin Roosevelt in part because
Rosabelle embraces new technologies in
part because the radio for example radio
absolutely and of course as television
becomes more prominent as the way of
choosing candidates change all of these
have been sort of important shifts over
time let's talk a little bit about the
the difference in the approach that a
historian takes towards well let's call
it the recent pass but nonetheless the
past versus say political science or
journalists who were very much who I
guess they could also study the past or
but but are typically focused on the the
present and watching things unspool well
I'd say the first thing is that
historians spend a lot of time talking
about you know when is something
officially history and by history we
don't mean yesterday right what that
tends to mean is when do we have
sufficient distance on events to begin
to take the long view and that is
roughly say 30 years that's often where
it kind of falls out so right now
historians are very interested in the
1970s and 1980s and they're a handful of
people who are doing more recent things
but you know I'd say roughly think I
don't know what does this election mean
ask me in 30 years and that I will be
able to begin to have an answer there
but the other reason that that's
particularly important to you historians
is that historians like to go to
archives historians like to go to
archives have papers be able to tell the
inside story based on the record that is
left behind now that doesn't mean
historians don't crunch numbers or do
interviews they do all of those things
as well but
and particularly when you're talking
about government there's a kind of lag
time in when you can find out what was
really going on so a lot of the ways in
which historians think about these sorts
of questions and what becomes history
are driven by again this is particularly
government but not exclusive to
government you know when are these
sources going to open up when are they
going to be available when can we both
have distance and find out what's really
going on exactly let's talk about
candidates pedigrees for a second
especially since the first Bush
presidency the number of the main
candidates the ultimate candidates for
president the parties candidates have
had what you might call elite pedigrees
they went to great schools like Yale and
Harvard why don't we see more populist
candidates with BIOS that are somewhat
biographies are somewhat more
representative of the American
electorate that's a really interesting
question I mean we should note this is a
devastating year for Yale right so we've
got to to Harvard candidates out there
and you know I would say it's not wholly
unusual unfortunately overall Harvard
presidents have tended to stack up a
little better in my estimation of Yale
presidents which is to say you know
Harvard can claim Theodore Roosevelt
Franklin Roosevelt John F Kennedy and
Yale has Taft and of course Clinton ed
some of the more recent Bush
presidencies as well both Bush
presidencies but I think it is an
interesting and important question I
mean both about sort of why is this
happening now but also how does this
change the kinds of ways that people
relate to the political system I mean it
is as I said important to note that it's
rather unusual to have right the
populist candidates have always been in
the minority which is to say when you
think particularly about the 20th
century I mean certainly there's been
Lyndon Johnson we had Harry Truman
though we kind of had Harry Truman by
accident we also kind of had Lyndon
Johnson by accident and then you have
Richard Nixon probably as
the most humble candidate elected in his
own right well he was a Duke graduate
right but he nonetheless I would say
both didn't come out of quite the same
elite world and was actually someone who
was able to channel a kind of resentment
against elites as part of his
presidential personality his campaign
appeal and such um so I think I mean I
don't have I suppose a full explanation
as to why this is the case but I think
it deserves a lot more discussion and a
lot more scrutiny than it's actually
gotten I mean both the question of
pedigree and access but also the simple
question of wealth not that Barack Obama
came from wealthy origins but what does
it mean to move in that kind of elite
world through most of your adult life
and how does it shape how you think
about the world I think those are really
important questions do Barack Obama and
Mitt Romney in your mind represent
obvious clear political traditions in
American history well that's an
interesting question you know I still
find Romney a bit hard to pin down as a
candidate I mean I suppose he represents
a tradition of figures trying to
position themselves properly to appeal
to the broadest possible electorate you
know I think it's very clear if you look
at someone like Paul Ryan you can see a
sort of ideological tradition that he
himself has described himself coming out
of that he talks about the books that
he's read the things that have shaped
his conservative worldview the kinds of
ideas that really drive him and I think
he's quite easy to situate in a kind of
trajectory of post-war conservative
American ideas and debates I think for
the presidential candidates it's a
little bit harder I mean I tend to think
of Obama really as much more of a
centrist president than many people
thought that he was going to be or than
many liberals thought that he was going
to be when he was elected but of course
from a conservative perspective many
people don't see that at all and so I
think this kind of gets back to my point
about
having the distance of history which is
to say let's see how it all turns out
and then we will answer that question in
in in another thirty years about where
they really fit in kind of the big
picture of American politics at the
moment we've a question coming in by
email from Essie this is a fairly
technical question but take a stab at it
it's actually a very technical question
but we'll give it a shot okay I may or
may not be able to do it is that is it
is it true that this this question has
to do with what everybody now calls
including the president Obama care his
health reform Act is it true that there
are present loopholes that give big
companies the right to dump their health
insurance policies and basically send
everyone straight into Obamacare yeah
you know I can see where that question
is coming you know actually because
there's a lot of talk about this sort of
thing but I couldn't tell you yeah the
technicalities on on that particular
question but that that worry yeah and
that concern is certainly something that
you see floating around a lot but
whether or not it has any basis I just I
don't really know my impulse is that I
don't think that it does but I have not
read that okay something for future
research um let's talk about parties
again for some political parties we're
essentially a two-party system in this
country I wonder do you think that
assuming adequate assuming not
adequately major financial resources but
we likely to see a serious run by a
third party candidate in our lifetimes
well the role of third parties is very
interesting I mean so the Republicans
are the most successful third will
really fourth party in terms of their
founding right they're the only one
that's really lasted the party of
Lincoln right which comes into being in
the 1850s and 1860s up but those were
rather particular circumstances Civil
War slavery sectional division so I mean
in terms of modern American politics by
which I mean the 20th century there have
been real moments where third party and
sometimes even fourth party candidates
made
pretty significant difference so we
mentioned that we're at the hundredth
anniversary of the 1912 election one of
the things that made that election so
interesting is that there were actually
four major serious candidates who each
got pretty substantial proportions of
the votes so there was Woodrow Wilson
running as a Democrat William Howard
Taft the incumbent president running as
the Republican though he comes in third
you have Teddy Roosevelt who is running
on the Progressive Party ticket and you
have Eugene Debs who is running on the
Socialist Party ticket in that moment
the Socialists get 6% of the vote they
don't win any electoral votes but it's
not in substantial proportion of the
vote Teddy Roosevelt of course gets a
much more substantial proportion comes
in second and Woodrow Wilson takes that
election with a plurality so I'd say the
story of third parties and you can see
this in other moments too 1948 is
another famous four party election but
what they tend to do is first of all
shape the particular election in which
they are involved they tend not to last
and the other interesting thing is that
they tend to be markers of a kind of
transitional moment in the structure of
the two existing parties so you look at
a moment like 1948 in which you have a
Progressive Party candidate who is Henry
Wallace you have Truman as the Democrat
you have wait who's the Republican in
1948 why am i forget doing right so
doing the Republican in 1948 then you
have Strom Thurmond running on a states
rights party within sort of a faction of
the Democratic Party but many people
look at that and in the long view see
that as the beginning of the kind of
transition of the white South out of the
Democratic Party into the Republican
Party and it's a process that takes
place over 30 years again a similar
story told it's George Wallace's
candidacies so I think those are the
roles that third parties tend to play at
this point in American politics you're
absolutely right it would take really a
tremendous amount of money to start out
making a run at the presidential level
there of course many other levels at
which third parties can play a pretty
significant role but so it does seem
like in
our moment the most likely scenario is a
very very rich guy deciding he's gonna
make a go of it for the presidency
someone like Michael Bloomberg or you
know like Ross Perot as we saw a couple
decades ago the time is flying by but I
want to I want to run through a few more
questions really quickly voter turnout
in 2008 of citizens vote of voting of
citizens of voting age in the u.s.
something like 64% voted a much higher
percentage of registered voters actually
cast ballots in brief what does that
reflect in your mind about our society
are you asking about why more but why
more people don't vote yes well I think
you know I think there are a lot of
answers to that question and I'm not
sure I have the definitive one my
instinct is that a lot of it has to do
with relatively kind of weak political
institutions in the United States which
is to say that though people identify
with parties you don't actually see
parties having the same kind of intimate
local role in people's lives that you
did in the 19th century when you had
much more like 80 85 % of of Americans
voting I think some of it has to do with
class some of it has to do with the fact
that Election Day is not a federal
holiday people are at work people are
busy so I think there are you know very
practical technical reasons and then
there are a lot of reasons about
political culture inequality class
structures political institutions so
that is a non answer to your question
fair enough
we'll take one from Jared who writes in
by livestream
he asks do the current political
trajectories end and I presume he means
in our in our in our country and in
political chaos or some form of
revolution or are they part of some
great pendulum swing and I guess we'll
have to sort of define what you think
trajectory means in this context but
well what do you think trajectory means
in this time well the way things are
going that's the way I take it yeah well
so revolution right this has always been
a persistent question I think the
possibilities for kind of genuine
revolutionary action in the
States have always been rather limited
in a whole variety of ways so that maybe
is not a word that we that we
necessarily want to hold on to or choose
it's very complicated word but in terms
of where we're going I mean I guess I
would have to fall back on my role as a
historian and say I don't know exactly I
mean we will see what happens
with this election and I think there is
really a sense in many ways that the
machinery of government has broken down
in significant ways and so I wouldn't be
surprised if we're actually on the cusp
of a period of reform of political
institutions which is to say as we were
talking about this question of
bipartisanship and the kinds of
deadlocks we've been seeing so much of
them have to do with particular
structures of the parties at this moment
even the ways that congressional
committees tend to work right now so I
wouldn't be surprised if in that limited
way we're on the verge of a real push
for some kind of structural change there
there still seems to me on a lot of the
biggest questions to be an awful lot of
consensus in the United States and this
has always been one of the one of the
real tensions of American history are we
a country of deep conflict or are we a
country in which a lot of the big
questions have always been pretty
settled and the range of political
debate is actually quite small and I
think we're at a moment when those
questions are coming to the fore again
any special plans for watching tonight's
debate no but I am gonna do it yeah my
my husband is a political cartoonist so
he's always very entertaining to watch
so he's often you know deep in the
minutiae and and and watching for the
moments of humor and energy so will he
be sketching but he's but he's an
entertaining partner to have a debate
good
well Beverly gage thank you so much for
joining us and thanks to all of you for
watching at Yale live I hope that you'll
join us again next time Eric Gershon at
Yale live thanks
you